okay hey guys Eric here again to show
you a division video we're going to
check out high-end weapons and
potentially crafting one because I don't
want the actual a.k the special gear
vendor selling but let's take a look at
that aka I was talking about
it's a classic ak-47 a high-end assault
rifle seems to have decent damage and
shoots at a decent rate not too fast 600
rpm take a look at the talents talents
are pretty important to the guns the
Blues have one talent the Purple's which
are the superiors have two and the high
end has three which kind of you know
pushes it head and shoulders above the
superior but I think I'm going to try
the going the named route here which has
the talents on it already it's called
The Liberator I'm gonna buy it
alright so I can't give you a bag of
that no that's alright you don't need to
give me a bag for that sir let's go and
craft ourselves our first high-end
weapon or at least my first one not sure
if you guys have one yet but let's take
a look there it is The Liberator let's
hope that we get higher end on the DPS
so we're praying for you know like a
7,500 role maybe maybe
come on yes 7513 DPS that seems pretty
good
currently I cannot unlock the two of the
three skills because I don't have enough
stat set which is kind of unfortunate
but you know we can give it a spin
anyways see how it does
alright let's check this Liberator out
shall we
here we go here we go
decent damage very accurate though
really stable digging it so far
and aesthetically I'm diggin it - the
right grip the right grip kind of makes
it a little wonky but it's a preset gun
you know it's early you got to roll with
the high and you get you know so we got
some sniper Reno's let's try to take
them out without our sniper we'll see
you keep the Liberator give them the
brightest from these snipers
Wow this gun is these got some
troublemakers I think this guns going to
be even better once owned once I can get
some some of the talents going because
that's really where the work it starts
to shine with high-end high-end weapons
well that was a look at the liberator
I'm so happy that this was the gun that
I chose to make I'm always been a fan of
the m4 ACRs in this game and it's just
super solid it's steady and I can't wait
to get enough stats to kind of push it
even farther with the perks I mean the
talents rather and yeah tell me what
high-end weapons you've either found or
what you guys are looking forward to
crafting and tell me your experience
with that you can stay tuned against
Wacom for continuing coverage of the
division and more stuff coming from us
you